.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Düstere Klänge *
In der Schweiz im Gefängnis zu sein,
ist kein Weltuntergang.
Mein "Reporter"-Kollege
Christof Franzen und ich
gehen für eine Woche
in die JVA Pöschwies.
Ich bin hinter der Kamera, er davor.
Die Banalität des Bösen
- Ja.
Aber auch die Komplexität des Bösen.
- Ja, ja.
Ich berichte seit über zehn Jahren
über Justizthemen.
Er ist zum ersten Mal
in einem Schweizer Gefängnis.
Für die Gesellschaft
gelten Sie als Mörder.- So ist es.
Sie haben mit Drogen gehandelt?
- Ja.
Ich bin das vierte Mal im Knast.
Wir wollen herausfinden,
was es bringt, Menschen zu strafen.
Ich wurde zu sechs Jahren
und neun Monaten verurteilt -
wegen bandenmässigem
Einbruchdiebstahl.- Ja.
Ich habe
eine zweijährige Freiheitsstrafe
wegen vorsätzlicher Tötung.
In der Zukunft
also ohne Messer in den Ausgang.
Am besten gar nicht mehr gehen.
Vielleicht ist das besser.
- Ja.
Sehen Sie das?
Das hat mir der Knast gebracht.
Ist das der Lohn?
- Da.
Make it rain.
Ohne Gefängnis
würde Anarchie herrschen.
Strafe muss sein.
Wer Einbrüche oder Morde begeht,
muss dafür bezahlen.
Das System Gefängnis
besteht ja schon seit eh und je.
Früher war es ein Kerker,
jetzt sieht es so aus.
Das ist fast besser.
Auch wenn es wie ein Hotel aussieht,
sitzt man am Ende des Tages
allein in seiner Zelle ...
... und hat viel Zeit
zum Nachdenken.
Zeit, um z.B. darüber nachzudenken,
wieso er
auf die schiefe Bahn geraten ist.
Wieso er seinen Platz
in unserer Gesellschaft
mit 30 Jahren
noch immer nicht gefunden hat.
Wieso er mit Stehlen begann
und schliesslich
zum Serieneinbrecher wurde.
Das Finanzielle war bei mir
ausschlaggebend dafür,
warum es so weit kam,
dass ich hier landete.
Ich brauchte Geld.
Ich bin bereit,
für Geld fast alles zu tun.
Ja.
- Geld löst deine Probleme.
Hat man manchmal
ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Ja ... Ich habe vor der Tat
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Darum achte ich darauf,
dass es keine Verletzte gibt -
keine Geschädigten sozusagen.
Darum wählte ich
diese Art von Kriminalität.
Ich habe keinen 1:1-Kontakt
mit jemand anderem.
Giorgio mit Anfang 20.
Yeah.
- Kurz vor seiner letzten Verhaftung.
# Okay, und ich mache d'Auge uf,
gseh nur Scheiss i dem Läbe.
# Probiere durehalte,
doch isch schwer zum Erträge.
# Ich gseh Bluet und Hass
und Träne uf de Strass.
# Ich frög mich immer: "Für was
isch das guet?" Säg mer das.
Er begann, sich einen Namen
als Rapper zu machen.
Daneben brach er quasi im Akkord
in Geschäftsliegenschaften ein
und finanzierte sich so
seinen aufwendigen Lebensstil.
# Weisch du, wie das isch,
wenn du is Heim gahsch mit drü?
# Dis Läbe isch beschisse
und du chasch gar nüt derfür.
# Riise Hass uf dini Mom,
läbsch dis Läbe ohni Plan.
# Am liebschte würd ich flüge,
so wiit flüge wien ich chan.
Yeah.
# Für was isch das guet, yeah.
Sie singen von jemandem,
der mit drei in ein Heim kam
und einen Hass auf seine Mutter hat.
Ist das Ihre Biografie?
- Ja, das ist sie.
Sie kamen mit drei Jahren
in ein Heim?- Genau.
Mit drei Jahren in ein Kinderheim.
Pilgerbrunnen hiess es.
Dann ging ich von Heim zu Heim,
von Pflegefamilie zu Pflegefamilie.
Dann ...
Irgendwann schlug ich
den kriminellen Weg ein.
Anstatt von ...
... Heim zu Heim, ging es
in Geschlossene, in Gefängnisse
oder Jugendstrafanstalten.
Sie kennen nichts anderes.
Mehr oder weniger.
Kann man so sagen.
Ja.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
R. wurde wegen Mordes
zu 18 Jahren verurteilt.
Zehn Jahre hat er schon verbüsst.
Der Vermögensverwalter, heute 67,
habe einen flüchtigen Bekannten
aus nächster Nähe erschossen.
Sein Motiv:
Geld und verletzter Stolz.
Ist das fast wie Ihr Zuhause?
Ja, man gewöhnt sich daran.
Ich habe eine einfache Philosophie:
Heimat ist dort,
wo man sich befindet.- Aha.
Oder dort, wo man sich wohlfühlt.
- Ich lebe einfach hier.
Ich kann mich gut arrangieren.
Ich habe in verschiedenen Ländern
gelebt.
Ich war sehr mobil.
Daher fällt es mir nicht so schwer.
- Aha.
Rein psychologisch.
Und v.a. vom Alter her.
Ich hatte mein Leben.- Ja.
Ich hatte ein gutes Leben.
Daher
spielt das eigentlich keine Rolle.
Ist das auch Teil des guten Lebens?
Ähm ... Ja ...
Es ist einfach
eine andere Perspektive.
Ich hatte früher 16-Std.-Tage.
Ich war schon halb verrückt.
Für mich ist das
wie eine Erholungsphase.- Ja.
Ich kann mich in meinem Alter
daran zurückerinnern,
was alles passiert ist.
Ich kann das aufarbeiten
und verarbeiten.
Darin sehe ich den positiven Aspekt.
Ich habe hier
viel Kontakt mit dem Pfarrer.- Ja.
Wir behandeln
allgemeine Lebensfragen.
Er ist
ein sehr guter Ansprechpartner.
Sind Sie gläubig?
- Ja, das war ich immer.
Immer?
- Ja.
Das ist ein sehr zentraler Punkt
in meinem Leben.
Wie passt das
mit Ihrer Tat zusammen?
Ja, also ...
Die Tat selber
hat noch einen anderen Aspekt.
Die Tat ist bestritten.
- Ja.
Denken Sie, Sie seien ...
... unschuldig bzw. ein Justizopfer?
- Das könnte man sagen.
Solche Geschichten
hören wir hier viele:
Menschen, die sich als Opfer sehen.
Menschen,
die sich ungerecht behandelt fühlen.
Menschen, die sagen,
sie seien harmlos und sollten darum
sofort entlassen werden.
Wenn man mit ihnen spricht ...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Man verspürt eine gewisse Empathie.
Man hat Mitgefühl.
Das ist die Gefahr,
wenn man ein paar Tage hier ist ...
Du darfst dich nicht ...
- ... und mit den Leuten spricht.
Du darfst dich nicht blenden lassen.
- Ja.
Du darfst nicht das Gefühl haben,
du kämst hier rein
sprichst 15-30 Min. mit jemandem
und könntest das besser einschätzen,
als all die Leute, die sich
seit Jahren mit ihnen befassen.
Ja.
* Düstere Klänge *
* Franzen ächzt. *
Wie haben Sie sich eingerichtet?
Es muss etwas wohnlich
und heimelig sein.
Man verbringt viel Zeit hier.
Dann soll es auch
etwas angenehm sein.
Nicht so stier,
nur mit weissen Wänden.
Ja.
Was ist mit Familienfotos?
- Die sind privat.
Andere Insassen
gehen hier ein und aus.- Ja.
Nicht alle sollten das sehen können.
- Ja.
Ich sehe überall nackte Frauen.
Fehlt das?
Das ist das Einzige, das fehlt.
Ist das so?
- Das ist die Nummer 1, die fehlt.
Vor dem Knast
standen die Frauen Schlange, sagt er.
# Das isch genau das,
wo alli Fraue wänd.
# Mini Seel het brännt,
das isch mis Tempramänt.
# I dem Läbe kriegt me gar nüt,
aber gar nüt me gschänkt.
Er wähnte sich auf der Überholspur:
höher, schneller, weiter.
Ein Leben im Scheinwerferlicht,
ohne Geldsorgen -
alles schien möglich.
- # Das isch Züri.
Ist es noch möglich,
einen normalen Job zu bekommen?
Mit dem Leumundszeugnis heutzutage
ist das schwierig.
Selbst für die Migros-Kasse ...
... muss man
ein Leumundszeugnis vorweisen.
Die Möglichkeiten sind klein:
Baustelle, Schwarzarbeit - aber das
ist auch schon wieder illegal.
Es geht immer ...
... weiter und weiter und weiter.
Haben Sie es versucht?
Ich musste vom RAV aus pro Monat
zwölf Bewerbungen abschicken.
Das machte ich
ungefähr vier Monate lang.
Ich kriegte jeden Monat
zwölf Absagen.
Ich merkte,
dass der Text vorgegeben war:
"Da sich anderes, besser quali-
fiziertes Personal beworben hat,
müssen wir Ihnen
leider eine Absage erteilen."
Kam es nie zu
einem Vorstellungsgespräch?- Nie.
Ich kriegte nur Absagen und wusste,
dass es am Leumundszeugnis liegt.
Ja.
Das bricht einem das Genick.
Und wie kommt es zum Schritt
zurück in die Straffälligkeit?
Über ehemalige Freunde?
Wie kommt man da wieder rein?
Früher
machte ich in einer Nacht 12'000 Fr.
Und jetzt soll ich mich
für 4'000 bis 4'500 Fr.
einen ganzen Monat
auf dem Bau kaputtarbeiten?
Es gibt so einfache Wege,
um an Geld zu kommen.
Die legalen Wege
sind schwer und steinig.
Gewisse trauen sich,
den entscheidenden Schritt zu machen
und diese rote Linie
zu überschreiten, und andere nicht.
Er hat diese rote Linie
in der Vergangenheit
immer wieder überschritten.
Petrit ebenfalls:
Der gebürtige Serbe, 39, hat im
grossen Stil mit Heroin gehandelt -
in der Hoffnung
auf das schnelle Geld.
Ja.
Wieso?
Etwas Kriminelles?
- Ja.
Schreckt die mögliche Strafe
nicht ab?
Haben Strafen
eine abschreckende Wirkung?
Und lässt sich diese Wirkung
mit härteren Strafen steigern?
Diese Fragen gehören
zu den am besten erforschten Themen
der Kriminologie.
Und die Antworten sind klar,
erfahren wir
an der Rechtswissenschaftlichen
Fakultät der Universität Fribourg.
Es wäre schön,
wenn es funktionieren würde.
Das wünschen wir uns alle.
Eine Art Gerät, mit dem man
etwas mehr oder weniger strafen
und so das Verhalten steuern könnte.
Das Hauptproblem: Das menschliche
Verhalten ist extrem komplex.
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Weil ...
... wir Menschen sind.
Wir lesen nicht in Büchern nach,
was passieren könnte.
Wir machen einfach mal.
Das kann man empirisch
sehr gut nachweisen:
Die Menschen
haben keine Rechtskenntnis.
Die meisten wissen nicht,
was passiert.
Sie wissen irgendwie, dass etwas
nicht erlaubt ist - normalerweise.
Im Bereich des Kernstrafrechts
wissen sie,
dass man Leute nicht töten,
verletzen, vergewaltigen,
einsperren usw. darf.
Aber was genau passiert,
wissen sie nicht.
Ob man für Diebstahl
drei, fünf oder acht Jahre gibt,
hat überhaupt keinen Einfluss.
Ob fünf oder sieben Jahre -
es ist einfach sehr lange.
Das ist wissenschaftlich
nicht umstritten?- Nein.
Die Empirie ist also eindeutig.
Trotzdem sind und bleiben diese
Fragen ein medialer Dauerbrenner.
Pflegen wir hierzulande die
Kuscheljustiz naiv und wirkungslos?
Braucht es tatsächlich mehr Härte
und strengere Gesetze?
Zu teuer, zu milde -
manchmal brauche es statt Kuschel-
justiz einfach die ganz harte Tour.
Härtere Strafen
sollen jetzt dagegen helfen.
Der Nationalrat
debattiert morgen darüber.
Sie können
politisch Kapital schlagen ...
... ohne Wirkung.
Sie können die Strafen raufsetzen,
das ändert aber nichts.
Wenn ich relativ sicher bin, nicht
entdeckt und verfolgt zu werden,
spielt das keine Rolle.
Entdeckungs-
und Bestrafungswahrscheinlichkeit
sind die zentralen Faktoren.
Was genau passiert,
spielt keine Rolle.
Also wie lange die Strafe ist?
- Genau.
Das spielt überhaupt keine Rolle.
Zentral ist,
dass es überhaupt eine Strafe gibt -
und zwar schnell.
"Höhere Strafen, also mehr Jahre,
schrecken andere ab."
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das der Fall ist.
Nein.
- Laut dessen, was wir gehört haben.
Logik 1:
Droht man mit härteren Strafen,
werden weniger Leute straffällig,
weil sie Angst vor der Strafe haben.
Und Logik 2: Wenn man die Leute,
die doch straffällig werden,
länger einsperrt,
beeindruckt es sie noch mehr.
Beides stimmt offensichtlich nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob die Politiker, die das fordern,
und die Leute, die das unterstützen,
wirklich an die Abschreckung denken,
dass man danach
in einem sichereren Land lebe.
Oder ist es
eine emotionale Reaktion:
"Die müssen in den Knast."
"Die wollen wir
in der Gesellschaft nicht."
Also wird ihnen zur Strafe
die Freiheit entzogen.
Und sie landen bei Andreas Naegeli,
dem Direktor der JVA Pöschwies.
Er soll aus ihnen
bessere Menschen machen -
indem er sie
z.B. zusätzlich bestraft,
wenn sie sich nicht
an die hier geltenden Regeln halten.
Fehlverhalten wird hier schnell
und konsequent sanktioniert -
mit maximal 20 Tagen Arrest.
Das ist für die ganz harten Fälle.
Nicht für die ganz harten Fälle,
sondern für jene,
die eine Arreststrafe erhalten.
Aber viele sagen ja,
es bräuchte mehr davon.
Das ist interessant.
- Nein.
Wenn das wirkt, könnte man ja sie
die ganze Haftzeit so einsperren.
Nein, um Himmels willen.
Das ist schon
nach relativ wenigen Tagen ...
Das setzt den Männern schon zu.
- Ja.
Sie können das Fenster nicht öffnen.
Sie hören, wie es hier drin hallt.
Man hört ja nur sich selber.
Man ist
absolut abgeschirmt von Reizen.
Das ist nicht anregend.
Das ist keine
lebensfreundliche Umgebung.
Also, daher ist das ...
Also, das ist nicht ...
Also,
es ist sicher nicht förderlich,
Menschen über eine längere Zeit
so leben zu lassen.
Arrest bedeutet: 23 Std. pro Tag
in der Zelle und eine Stunde Hofgang.
Aha, ja, das ist ...
... wie man es sich vorstellt, oder?
- Ja.
Das ist extra so trist gehalten,
oder?
Ja, ja.
- Nehme ich an.
Ja ...
Strafe müsse sein, sagt Naegeli.
Strafe sei aber nur ein Teil
auf dem Weg zur Besserung.
Um wirklich weiterzukommen,
braucht es natürlich auch Einsicht
vonseiten der Männer.
Das braucht es.
- Wäre das der Idealfall?
Auf jeden Fall.
- Wie oft kommt das vor?
Ja, ziemlich oft.
Die Angebote, die wir haben -
sei das eine Arbeit zu lernen,
einen geregelten Alltag zu haben ...
Man hat hier eine Struktur,
die einem Halt gibt.
Man hat vonseiten des Personals
auch professionelle Leute,
die Vorbilder für einen sein können.
Sie können einen
sozusagen darin anleiten,
was gesellschaftlich erwartet
und akzeptiert wird -
vom Normalmenschen ausgehend.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wie alt sind Sie?
- 23.
23?
- Ja.- Aha.
Wie lange sind Sie schon hier?
- Bald drei Jahre in Pöschwies.
Und in der Jugend auch schon ...
- Nein.
Nein.
Kleinigkeiten, aber nichts Grosses.
Was sind Kleinigkeiten?
Vielleicht mal mit Gras erwischt,
aber keine gravierenden Vorfälle.
Bis er mit 18 im Ausgang
mit einem Messer
auf zwei junge Männer einstach.
Wie kam es dazu?
Durch Provokation oder ...
Ja, es gab einen Streit,
der sich dann hochschaukelte.
Wie ist es,
wenn man so jung hierherkommt?
Man muss für das einstehen,
was man will und was man nicht will.
Ich bin der jüngste Insasse hier.
- Aha.
Es ist nicht
wie in den amerikanischen Filmen,
wo man in eine Zelle gerufen wird
und dann ...
Aber trotzdem ...
Sagen wir es so:
Ein selbstbewusstes Auftreten hilft.
Hilft das?
- Ja.
Als Abschreckung?
- Nein, einfach ...
Ist das eher verbal?
- Nein, also ...
Man ist hier ja nicht
mit Gutmenschen eingeschlossen.
Das ist kein Gutmenschen-Camp.
Teils sind hier Leute ...
... denen gewisse Dinge egal sind.
Die überlegen nicht zweimal.
Es ist ein Eigentor,
auch für die Gesellschaft.
Sie bessern sich hier drin nicht.
- Ja.
Man passt sich automatisch
dem Umfeld an.
Für ein Jahr
kann man sich vielleicht abkoppeln,
aber ein paar Jahre hier
hinterlassen Spuren, sicher.
* Düstere Klänge *
Verändert man sich hier drin?
Ich glaube,
ich bin immer noch derselbe.
Natürlich
vermisse ich gewisse Dinge,
Kulturelles z.B.,
aber das bringt mich nicht um.
Ich bin anders.
Ich bin sehr nach Asien ...
Meine Frau war Asiatin.
Ich bin sehr asienorientiert.
Sie leben im Prinzip im Innern.
- Ja.
Das ist für mich
hier drin auch der Fall.
Ich lebe für mich, bei mir.
Ich bin bei mir.
Es berührt mich nicht so,
was aussen alles so abläuft.
Ja.
* Düstere Klänge *
Ich kam als 19-, 20-Jähriger
ohne Plan hier rein.
Früher stahl ich Autos,
fuhr etwas mit ihnen rum
und liess sie dann stehen.
Ich wusste nicht,
was damit anfangen.
Heute hätte ich fünf Kontakte.
Ich könnte das Auto
für gutes Geld verscherbeln.
Sie schleifen die Seriennummer ab,
lackieren es neu ...
... und ab die Post.
Jetzt wäre es einfacher.
- Ja.
Ich habe jetzt viele Kontakte.
Ich könnte an Drogen oder Waffen
kommen.
Alles wäre möglich.
Aber natürlich sollte der Weg
als Erstes legal sein.
Das ist klar.
Aus Amateuren können hier drin
also Profiverbrecher werden.
Das Ziel des Strafvollzuges
ist freilich ein anderes:
diese Menschen
auf die Freiheit vorzubereiten -
und das in einem Umfeld,
das mit der Freiheit
wenig bis nichts zu tun hat.
Die Männer bezahlen keine Miete,
sie waschen ihre Wäsche nicht,
sie müssen nicht einkaufen,
nicht kochen ...
Sie müssen gerade mal
ihre eigene Zelle putzen.
Bei einem Konflikt
kann man sich an sehr viele
professionelle Leute wenden.
Unser Arztdienst ist gut dotiert.
Man kann quasi
über die Strasse zum Arzt gehen.
Bei seelischer Not
bieten wir Seelsorge an.
Wir haben einen Sozialarbeiter.
Und die Vollzugsmitarbeiter selbst
haben auch Kompetenzen.
Das ist in der Freiheit nicht so.
Man kann nicht einfach schnippen
und dann erscheint
ein ganzes Netzwerk an Leuten,
die professionell dabei helfen,
das Problem zu lösen.
Wieder
auf eigenen Beinen zu stehen ...
Man verlernt das normale Leben.
- Ja, so ist es.
Um diesem Problem zu begegnen,
erfolgt der Strafvollzug -
wenn immer möglich - progressiv:
Von einer geschlossenen Anstalt
geht es irgendwann in eine offene.
Immer mehr Freiräume sollen helfen,
sich schrittweise wieder
in die Gesellschaft einzugliedern.
Giorgio hatte diese Chance auch.
Er bewährte sich allerdings nicht
im offenen Vollzug.
Darum ging es zurück
in die Geschlossenheit.
War eine Lehre nie ein Thema?
- Das kann man hier.
Aber für Sie ...
- Das war keine Option für mich.
Nein.
- Warum nicht?
Weil ...
Das sind B-Lehren,
wie ich das nenne.
Oder Anlehren.
Man kann
nicht Automechaniker lernen,
sondern nur Reifenpraktiker.
- Ja, immerhin.
Und Schreiner
oder Bäcker oder Gärtner?
Ich kann das unter den Umständen
hier drin sowieso nicht durchziehen.
Ich muss mich
auf anderes konzentrieren.- Worauf?
V.a., damit klarzukommen.
- Ja.
Im Strafvollzug
herrscht Arbeitspflicht.
Es gibt verschiedene
einfache handwerkliche Gewerbe.
Man hat etwas zu tun
und man verdient Geld.
Aber das werde ich in meinem Leben
nicht brauchen.
Aber ja ...
Was könnte Sie davon abhalten,
noch mal so eine Tat zu begehen?
Ich selber und meine Familie.
Die Leute um mich herum.
Das ist am wichtigsten im Gefängnis:
Der Kontakt zu aussen zählt.
Den Boden
nicht unter den Füssen zu verlieren.
99 % der Leute hier drin
kommen irgendwann wieder raus.
Was für Leute lässt man da raus?
Waren sie bis am Ende
im geschlossenen Vollzug,
oder hatten sie eine Chance,
Schritt für Schritt zurückzukommen?
Ich habe draussen eine Familie
und eine Lehrstelle.
Ich könnte wieder rausgehen.
Merci.
Petrit wird nach seiner Entlassung
ausgeschafft -
und will in Serbien
noch mal ganz neu anfangen.
Dann ist es zu spät.
Aber ein normales Leben
mit Frau und Kindern ...
Das wäre doch ein Grund,
um nicht mehr zurückzukommen.
Strafen können wirken,
sie können aber auch schaden.
Aber sie müssen sein.
Und es braucht einen Ort,
wo sie vollzogen werden.
Das sind seit jeher Gefängnisse.
Ich sehe keine andere Lösung.
Nein, ich auch nicht.
Es befriedigt auch die Gesellschaft
ein Stück weit.
Das ist auch legitim.
- Ja.
Es geht um Sühne.
Und ein Stück weit
vielleicht sogar um Rache.
Dass man nicht selber hingeht
und den verprügelt oder so,
sondern dass der Staat
das in unserem Namen macht.
Und wenn er es nicht macht ...
Ja ...
... besteht natürlich die Gefahr,
dass es jemand selbst versucht.
Wie erfolgreich ist der
Zürcher Strafvollzug darüber hinaus?
Eine Studie zeigt:
Etwa jeder siebte Gewalt-
und Sexualstraftäter wird rückfällig.
Die grosse Mehrheit der Gefangenen
sind allerdings Ausländer.
Und die werden
nach der Entlassung ausgeschafft,
ihre Rückfälligkeit
also gar nicht erfasst.
Ein paar Wochen später.
Wir sind zurück in der JVA Pöschwies.
Wir warten gespannt auf ihn.
* Lachen *
Da bist du sieben Jahre hier
und dann ...
Giorgio hat seine Strafe
bis auf den letzten Tag abgesessen.
Heute wird er entlassen.
Morgen.
- Morgen.
Was haben Sie
in den letzten Stunden gemacht?
Gezittert und gezittert.
Ich konnte nicht schlafen.
Ich war die ganze Nacht wach
und drehte mich im Bett.
Gab es gestern ein Fest
oder einen Abschied?
Leider nicht.
Ich kriegte drei Tage vor der
Entlassung noch einen Einschluss.
Wieso?
- Wegen einer positiven Urin...
...kontrolle auf THC.
- Aha.
Also Haschisch.
Wegen drei Tagen
sperrten sie mich noch ein.
Eigentlich wären es 14 Tage.
- Ja.
Aber Ende der Strafe
ist Ende der Strafe.
Die letzten drei Tage
war ich in der Zelle.
Jetzt geht es von 0 auf 100 -
aus der Zelle ohne Fernseher
direkt in die Freiheit.
Sie konnten sich
also nicht verabschieden?
Praktisch nicht.
Bei den engsten Freunden schon.
Beim Rest will ich das
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Leute kommen, Leute gehen.
- Ja.
Ich kam allein und ich gehe allein,
wie Sie sehen.
Wie fühlt es sich an,
nach sieben Jahren?
War das eine lange Zeit?
Als würde ein riesiger Stein
von meinen Schultern fallen.
Ich fühle mich erleichtert.
Ja.
- Ja.
Gut, gehen wir.
- Auf.
Auch von mir: alles Gute.
- Ihnen auch. Danke schön.
Viel Erfolg draussen.
Hoffentlich läuft es gut.
Auf Nimmerwiedersehen.
- Gut.
Das ist alles.
Mein ganzes Hab und Gut
der letzten sieben Jahre.
Haben Sie die Bilder mitgenommen?
- Nein, keine.- Keine.
Ein Freund
erwartet ihn vor dieser Tür -
und natürlich auch die Freiheit.
Boah.
Zieh mal die Maske aus, Bro.
Blick nach vorne, oder?
Ab in die Freiheit, Bro.
- Ab in die Zukunft.
Wie geht es weiter? Wissen Sie das?
Jetzt gehe ich vermutlich
erst mal nach Hause.
Dann schauen wir weiter.
- Wo ist das?
Zu meiner Schwester.
Dann habe ich hier
viele bunte Scheine.
Sehen Sie das?
- Ja.
Das hat mir der Knast gebracht.
Ist das der Lohn?
- Da.
Make it rain.
Investieren Sie das?
- Jetzt wird investiert.
Ja.
Wissen Sie, wie es weitergeht?
Eigentlich nicht.
- Eine Arbeit oder etwas?
Noch nicht.
Ich hoffe, jemand meldet sich
und bietet mir einen Job an.
Ich nehme alles.
- Ja.
Lass uns gehen, Mann.
Weg von diesem dreckigen Ort.
Nie mehr, Mann.
Ich glaube,
wir werden noch von ihm hören -
musikalisch, hoffe ich.
Es kann auch anders kommen.
Ich glaube auch,
dass wir noch von ihm hören.
Ja, gut, gehen wir weiter.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021